welcome to the exciting world of
business analytics in this tutorial
video we will embark on a journey to
unravel the fundamental concepts and
principles that drive successful data
driven decision making in the corporate
Realm business analytics is the Art and
Science of transforming raw data into
meaningful insights empowering
organizations to make informed choices
optimize operations and gain a
Competitive Edge as businesses
increasingly rely on data to navigate
the complexities of today's market
mastering the fundamentals of analytics
has become Paramount throughout the
tutorial we will explore key components
such as data collection data analysis
and interpretation techniques we will
dwell into statistical models data
visualization and Predictive Analytics
equipping you with the tools to extract
valuable patterns and Trends from vast
data sets moreover we will uncover how
business analytics Fosters a culture of
evidence-based decision making driving
Innovation and growth get ready to
unlock the potential of data driven
insights and become a catalyst for
change in your organization
in this business analytics Basics course
we will learn the following first we
will understand what business analytics
is then the business processes and
business Process Management followed by
that we will look into what is business
analyst and how to become one next we'll
guide you through the business analyst
roadmap and the top business analyst
certifications
finally we will learn the fundamentals
and Hands-On the top three business
analytics tools Tableau power bi and
Excel join us as we demystify the world
of business analytics and Empower you to
harness the power of data to drive
strategic success let's Dive In
if these are the types of videos you
would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press on that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us if you are one of the aspiring
business analyst looking for online
training graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch carriers with business
analytics by learning from the experts
then try giving shot to our simply
learns postgraduate program in business
analysis in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft the link in the
description box should navigate to the
home page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
but before we begin let's take a minute
to hear from our Learners about their
success Journey post graduating from
Simply learns business analytics
training program I started working for
Amazon as business operations associated
I want to move into a technical job
profile but not in the software
development field so after a lot of
consideration and research I chose
business analysis as the next
destination in my professional journey I
am proud to say that I've cracked
another job at Comcast that I'll be
earning 354 percentage more than
whatever earning at Amazon I am Santosh
venkatesh I live in Chennai I have
turned my career around with the help of
synthesis I have done the post
graduation program in business analysis
with third University from simpliano I
took this course when I was in the
second year of my business operations
associate job in retrospect I should
have done it sooner as my life changed
for the better as a result
I even got a offer from Flex even before
completing the course where I am
currently working as a business analyst
I'm proud to say that I've cracked
another job at Comcast where I'll be
joining as a business analyst shortly
there I'll be earning 354 percentage
more than what I was earning at Amazon
so basically in a span of 10 months I
have increased my income by 354
percentage which I'm happy and excited
about
retainers were experts in their
respective Fields whatever they thought
us was quite simple to understand and
straightforward even though I was fairly
new to this film it was great to be able
to learn on the weekends as well as to
upload clearing sessions
even before starting of course I had
access to all the training modules and
everything seemed very easy
so the technical stuffs and also the
tools were very clear who loves to
Simply learn
I would like to tell anyone who's trying
to achieve something they want to
motivate themselves and to accept the
reality one cannot grow until he's
willing to grow you need to take action
rather than just keep procrastinating so
take the first step today and keep
learning it's no surprise that business
analytics and business intelligence are
two of the fastest growing markets in
the world
organizations today are generating data
at a rapid rate there is a need to use
this business data and make smarter
decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact-based decision
making on the other hand business
intelligence of bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively
consider this example suppose you sell
homemade chocolates through an online
store business intelligence provides
meaningful insights into the past and
current state of your business bi tells
you that sales of your milk chocolate
have spiked up in Texas the past two
weeks so you decide to manufacture more
milk chocolates to keep up with demand
business analytics asks why did sales of
milk chocolate Spike up in Texas by
scrutinizing your website data you
learned that most traffic has come from
a post by a food blogger based in Texas
who like to make chocolate
this Insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States
using cutting-edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as Microsoft
Excel SQL power bi and Tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth first of all let's
understand what business Process
Management is
business process management or BPM as an
organizational discipline in which a
firm examines all of the operation
processes collectively and individually
through this assessment companies aim to
identify areas of improvement to create
a more efficient and effective business
environment in simple terms business
Process Management is all about
optimizing and improving companies
business processes that serve customers
and eventually bring the pile of Revenue
BPM is vast discipline that by
definition is dynamic given the
continually changing organization roles
regulations method corporate goals and
other Factor it contains BPM has evolved
with time to accept a wide range of
optimization approaches from Six Sigma
and lean management to a child we'll
discover these approaches in depth on
some other day first let's dive deep
into the details of BPM if we break down
nuts and bolts of business Process
Management we'll find out three key
factors the first one is of course
business processes the second one will
be the set of inputs and the third one
will be the output retrieved after
processing presented inputs for example
consider the bank loan application
process here the customer will supply an
electronic application form via the
bank's website to receive the desired
loan plan let's say a home loan in this
case initially the input provided by the
customer will go into the loan
application process now the loan process
is not one small process there are
multiple operations and regulations
involved in it such as credit checkups
quality control loan management
underwriting
Etc all these tasks are cumulatively
considered as business processes as
mentioned earlier all these processes
will start once the customer provides
some sort of input in this case it is an
electronic application which will be
forwarded to the salesperson by Banks it
team by evaluating the submitted
electronic application A salesperson
will formulate the list of loan products
in order to present them to the customer
but if a customer is interested in some
specific banking product for instance
Home Loan in such a case the sales
person will provide customer details
about home loan a home loan has certain
eligibility criteria which customer will
have to fulfill so salesperson will ask
for setup documents such as ID proof
income Source or salary slip property
documents Etc this initial phase of loan
application is also known as
pre-qualification process
in the next phase the administrative
team will evaluate all the documents
submitted by the customer and forward
them to the credit analyst system at
this point the credit department
receives the application and the first
step is to analyze it for accuracy
genuineness and completeness
if all the needed fields are not filled
out the application will be returned to
the borrower or credit analyst who will
contact the borrower to get the missing
information
the credit team uses the loan
origination system to determine a
borrower's credit worthiness a good Los
will help A lender Bank set up workflows
to process a loan it may automatically
flag files that have missing needed
fills return them to the borrower and
tell the sales department that they need
to be reworked to manage this Tech a new
Department of information and Technology
will also come into play this particular
step of application evaluation is also
known as underwriting process in the
next phase the credit decisions are made
if customer fulfills all required
criteria the application will be
approved or if the customer lacks
somewhere the application will be
rejected in the next phase quality
assurance will be achieved because
lending is highly regulated business
Banks rely heavily on the quality check
stage of loan origination process the
application is routed to the quality
assurance team which Compares crucial
variables to internal and external
standards and regulations this is the
finest type of loan procedure before it
is submitted for funding now consider
all these processes altogether each
process works on feedback of other
process or some new input hence managing
every input and process can increase the
speed of business operation by removing
internal miscommunications service
delays customer complaints Etc and BPM
is the field of management that exactly
Works towards achieving that in short to
Define it in more simple terms I would
say BPM is all about managing multiple
input streams and intercommunication of
business processes to generate desired
business outcome within the least amount
of time possible
this BPM comprises of three main pillars
people processes and Technology all
three aspects are required to work hand
in hand for a BPM project to be
successful the business process needs to
be fit for purpose and actually satisfy
the demand for all the stakeholders
having said that let's discover the life
cycle of business Process Management
technology and management both are
crucial factors for BPM so the life
cycle commences the collaboration of
both with five standard steps the first
one is design then we have model
implement
Monitor and finally optimize
a large team of I.T and management
experts is required to construct the BPM
project
the management team will study related
set of business processes in great
detail and then try to redesign it with
the objective of optimizing it so that
it becomes more purpose oriented all of
this happens during the design phase of
the project here all the processes are
carefully designed to be as
straightforward as possible by making
use of standardization and it automation
that is why the space can be completed
in a shorter period of time next we have
as a modeling phase
during this phase the process gets
documented in the form open activity
model it allows experts to simulate the
system's behavior and try out different
scenarios through a what-if approach
once the process is approved by hire
management by looking at the modeling
and simulation sheet it is then executed
and deployed over the information system
phase of business Process Management is
known as implementation phase here if
management finds out some discrepancy
the corrections can be made by employing
standard methods and automation
the fourth page of BPM is monitoring
in this phase the performance of
business process is monitored to see if
anything goes wrong
if any problem occurs during the
monitoring phase it will be further
optimized in the next phase of business
Process Management this phase is known
as optimization often this phase remains
continuously under the Run since the
good BPM always improves its business
processes on an ongoing basis moving
ahead let's talk about the benefits of
business Process Management
the first benefit is increased
visibility of business processes a good
BPM implementation will increase the
visibility of banks activities making it
easy to Monitor and control the critical
business processes of the bank
vpm also provides management increased
ability to identify bottlenecks in
simple words a process bottleneck is a
work stage that gets more work request
then it can process at its maximum
throughput capacity an example of a
short-term bottleneck would be a skilled
employee taking a few days off if this
occurs planned operations will not be
done on time leading to the drift in
business performance the other type of
bottleneck would be a long-term
bottleneck it occurs all the time and
can significantly slow down production
an example of long-term bottleneck is
when a machine is not efficient enough
and as a result has a long Cube BPM can
help companies make improvements and
reassign resources to meet customer
demands by identifying this bottlenecks
the next benefit of BPM is reduce lead
time by controlling all business
processes altogether and monitoring each
process in a silo BPM increases the
accuracy and speed of business
operations for example the loan
application process that could have
taken months can now be finished within
weeks because of Control process
handling by BPM this increase efficiency
allows Banks to convert leads into
potential customers with no time so
definitely this is the hottest benefit
that BPM has to offer
the next benefit is a clear definition
of employee roles
a good BPM ensures planning Optimum
roles and duties for the teams as well
as employees since people resources is
also the important factor BPM aims to
manage the BPM system prevents
unfortunate situations where a customer
who phone to inquire about a loan
application is transferred from one
individual to the next and next with all
of them saying sorry it's not my
decision to make but let me transfer you
to the person who deals with it BPM
enables a cross-functional approach to
avoid this scenario so the work is
automatically moved from one desk to the
another without any need for manual
intervention the sixth benefit is
Unified systems and operations since in
BPM no process remains in a silo by
itself all processes come closer to each
other making business a complete unified
system
the last benefit on our list is expanded
growth potential as discussed earlier a
successful BPM increases customer
happiness and Lead conversion which
directly increases a company's revenue
and market value business analyst is a
professional who is responsible for
Bridging the Gap between it and business
teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense so you should have a clear
understanding of the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features write use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and the motive behind the
problem so let's have a look at the top
skills to become a successful business
analyst the first skill we have is
understanding the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improved revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increasing marketing budget according to
the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill a business
analyst would have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says five percent of
the people think 10 percent of the
people think they think and the other 85
percent would rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts require good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession if
you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point the use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders
non-verbal communication skills enable
the effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills business analysts
also perform cost benefit analysis to
conduct an assessment of the benefits
and costs anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have an act to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design confirms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation date of wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deep player tidier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualize Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboot reports are developed by
business analysts to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth scale in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems while business analysts are
generally not responsible for making
decisions regarding project Solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding Gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assist decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution now let me ask you
guys one interesting question what is
the primary goal of conducting a SWOT
analysis option A identify market trends
and customer preferences
can be accessing the financial viability
of a business venture option C
evaluating the internal and external
factors impacting a business option D
developing strategies for product
development and Innovations please
answer in the comment section below and
we will update the answer in the pin
comment you can also pause the video
give it a thought and answer in the
comment section now let's dive back into
our video business analysis is like
being a detective for a company it helps
a company figure out what it needs and
how to make things better business
analysis is done for all sort of things
a company wants to do whether big or
small it can be a part of specific
project or ongoing as the company grows
and improves think of it this way
business analysis helps a company
understand where it is right now where
it wants to go and how it gets there
it's like looking at a map and planning
the best route for a Journey it's
important because it helps the company
make smart decision and find ways to
create value for the people involved
so if you are into solving Mysteries and
helping companies grow business analysts
might be the perfect role for you
so till now you must have gotten an idea
of what business analysis is now we will
see who is a business analyst a business
analyst is a person who performs
business analysis tasks described in a
bab okay which is the business analysis
body of knowledge
no matter their job title or
organizational role business analysts
are responsible for discovering and
analyzing information from a variety of
source within expertise including tools
processes documentations and
stakeholders
now let's see what business analysts do
the activities that business analysts
perform includes business analyst
understanding Enterprise problems and
goals analyzing needs and solutions
formulate strategies Drive changes and
facilitates stakeholders collaboration
moving ahead with the positions that we
have in the business and let's discuss
with the education and skills needed for
the career path let's begin with
discussing the typical salary range of
an entry-level business analyst position
it's important to keep in mind that the
salary figure depends on various factors
such as location industry and Company
size however we can provide a general
idea of what you might expect
for entry-level business analyst in
India the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is typically between 3
lakh to 6 lakh per annum and in the US
the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is approximately
between 50 000 US dollar to 70 000 US
dollar per annum
now let's see education and Foundation
first you will need to get a bachelor
degree in business and administration
computer science or relatable feed it's
like building a strong Foundation of
your career to boost your credentials
you can also consider getting
certifications after that sharpen your
skills acquire domain knowledge and
develop your analytical skills by
learning tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software these are like
secret weapons that will help you
analyze data and find important insights
you should also learn problem solving
methods and how the model processes it's
like becoming a problem solving
superhero now hands-on experience to
really level up look for internships
entry-level positions or projects within
your organization this will give you a
practical experience and allows you to
contribute to the requirements Gathering
documentation and testing it's like
going to on a real life mission and
making a tangible impact by following
these steps you will be well on your way
to become a skilled business analyst you
will be the hero who has businesses make
smart decision and drive success
now let's talk about senior business
analyst salary
for senior level business analysis in
India the salary range can be between 6
lakh per annum to 12 lakh per annum
in the U.S the salary range of a senior
business analyst is typically between 70
000 US dollar to 100 000 US dollar per
annum for education and Foundation
consider pursuing a master's degree in
Business Administration or a relatable
field to depend your knowledge and
expertise explore Advanced certification
such as certified business analyst
professional or project management
professional acquired domain knowledge
continue expanding your understanding of
the industry and its strength challenges
and emerging Technologies develop a deep
understanding of specific business
domain with the industry
next analytical skill development
enhance your data analysis capabilities
by exploring Advanced Technologies
predictive modeling and data
visualization
familiarize yourself with business
intelligence tools and advanced
analytics platforms hands-on experience
take the lead on large projects and
handle critical business analysis
activities
mentor and support Junior analysts
provide them with guidance and
assistance remember the key is to
continue learning gaining practical
experience and staying up to date with
the industry Trends good luck with your
business analysis Journey after that we
have lead business analyst the salary
range of a lead business analyst in
India can vary from 12 lakh per annum to
25 lakh per annum and in the US the
salary range for lead business analyst
is typically between 100 000 US dollar
to 150 000 US dollar next education and
Foundation take Advanced certification
and specialized training in leadership
and business strategy
you should also acquire domain knowledge
become an expert in your industry by
staying up to date on Trends
regularizing on new technologies next
analytical skills development is very
important develop expertise in advanced
analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence learn about
tools and Technologies for predictive
analysis and data-driven decision making
next we have business analysis
Technologies Master the art of
facilitating and negotiating in complex
stackholders engagement
last hands-on experience take the lead
on strategic initiatives and large-scale
projects play a significant role in
shaping your organization's business
analysis processes and methodologies
everyone processes at their own pace
based on their skills opportunities and
Industry demands keep seeking
professional development take on
challenging tasks and build strong
relationship with the industry to
accelerate your growth as a business
analyst who is a business analyst
a business analyst is a person who works
with companies to study their systems
services and products in order to
enhance present operation and come to
profitable judgments
a business analyst
evaluates the business model and how to
integrate it with technology to assist
organization in documented business
processes a business analyst is
responsible for processing and analyzing
the products and services to make
profitable decision to improve the
financial activities of the organization
business analysts handle all the
requirements demanded by the clients and
convey them to the product development
team now it's time to learn skills
required to become business analyst
analytical skills and critical thinking
great Achievers are great thinkers
the role of the business analyst comes
at the beginning of the software
development lifecycle a business analyst
must analyze the client requirements
effectively critical thinking helps the
analyst in examining different
situations and providing a solution
communication skill every role demands
communication skill but communication is
the key for every business analyst they
are supposed to have talked with
stakeholders a good business analyst
needs to have communication in different
phases be it with clients product
development team or the implementation
team for instance if a product needs to
be implemented then it is the duty of a
business analyst to communicate with the
clients regarding requirement clearly
otherwise the entire project May
collapse as a business analyst
facilitating meeting is very important
first point to boost your confidence if
you have good communication skill
database and SQL
SQL is an important skill that every
business analyst needs to understand a
database is a software to store the data
business analysts should have hands-on
experience on SQL from which they can
fetch data from these databases so it's
better to know MySQL Oracle DB no SQL or
mongodb
programming skills it's good to know
programming languages like python or r
business analysts have to deal with lots
of data that are beyond the limits using
spreadsheets so if you know Python
programming language it helps in
analyzing the data as well as we can
easily integrate it with SQL databases
to automate tasks
R also works in the same way R helps to
create interactive graphs and help in
analyzing the data
reports and dashboards business
dashboards are increasingly seen to help
business analysts to produce data in an
insightful way
dashboards are Consolidated with charts
and graphs on a single screen the
purpose of dashboard is to help business
analysts by allowing them to gather and
analyze the data let's say we have 10
sets of people working on a project we
have to maintain a dashboard in such a
way that it is understandable and
accessible to everyone so that everyone
can understand the growth of the project
these were some of the important skills
business analysts need to have
how to become a business analyst if you
are a fresher this is a very important
part
ly it's essential to decide and
concentrate on the fundamentals of the
business analytics understanding the
fundamentals and choosing the right path
are crucial in every field start
learning the fundamentals of business
analytics first and start mastering it
pursue the related course it's a
reminder to you to have a look at the
business analyst master program link
which is given in the description box
below
you can take up a business management
course and get certified to become
industry ready
internship an internship is a fantastic
way to learn more about a field or job
you might like to pursue internship in
business analytics will help you deal
with real-time experience working in
Industry this will automatically improve
your resume start taking up real-time
projects on Business Development and
Analytics lastly apply for a job
build a portfolio including your
practical experience the portfolio
should consider all the internships and
projects you will be qualified to apply
for a job after you get all the
experience necessary this used by a
business analyst we have covered some of
the important tools frequently used by
business analyst based on its use
project management tool jira the
collaboration tools jira and Confluence
are very practical to collaborate
effectively on projects and share
requirements every business analyst has
to be at least familiar with jeera by
using platforms like jira all business
stakeholders May engage with various
teams and view the status of their
project
fellow is a project management platform
businesses use for teamwork and task
organization dividing the work into
columns on a board enables you to manage
your projects and effort dividing
complicated projects into smaller more
manageable and reliable chunks of Labor
help simplify and standardize your work
so for this purpose Trello is very
important tool
data visualization
the main use of data visualization tools
is the ability to quickly solve business
related problems Tableau is the prime
software for data visualization it
creates efficient visualization which
makes the stakeholders understand the
data more effectively
power bi is a software created by
Microsoft that meets your analytical and
business needs a visit allows access to
data even when using third-party
programs and services for instance you
can integrate it with SQL Server you can
enable python with power bi tool that
offers customizable visualization by
including data normalization and
purification the functionality of a
desktop program can be greatly increased
using power bi as we have already
learned reports and documentation is the
key skill for a business analyst to
create report and documentation we use
Google Docs Google Docs provide you with
templates for business research business
analyst may share and collaborate on
documents effectively using Google Docs
with the use of Google docs business
analyst can communicate with
stakeholders about any kind of file or
document
Microsoft PowerPoint as we previously
discussed good presentation skill is
always counted for a business analyst a
business analyst must have ability to
present project teachings to their
stakeholders so it's necessary to learn
Microsoft PowerPoint these were the
important tools for a business analyst
to manage their work now comes roles and
responsibility played by a business
analyst in Industry a business analyst
has a variety of roles and
responsibility therefore it is crucial
to understand thoroughly the roles and
responsibility held by business analyst
before learning how to become one
a business analyst pinpoints the goals
and issues of a company's business and
develops profitable Solutions
the assembled stakeholders and business
requirements they help in analyzing and
evaluating business processes an
organization has and identify the area
of improvement
business analysts collaborate with the
development team to create a plan for
addressing a specific issue they
aggressively offer feedback on the
design of a software program and
integrate the newly created features
that a company needs
business analysts evaluate companies
functional and non-functional
requirement different roles performed by
a business analyst are data analyst
business architect system architect and
product manager these are the roles
which are interdependent on a business
analyst in an organization so the top
companies hiring a business analyst
there are Accenture IBM Deloitte TCS
VMware McKinsey and Company we can also
include meta in this list this is the
job description provided by Accenture
for a business analyst role key
responsibility will include working with
clients and Technical Resources to
identify their business problem and
developing the analytical solution good
knowledge and understanding of digital
application
planning and managing business diagnosis
and planning activities understanding
and analyze functional impacts on front
to back application design and document
new process and system changes
performing interpreting requirement
analysis to identify value creation
opportunities for clients on average
Accenture offers 76
000 dollars per year for a business
analyst Rule now we will see job
description in IBM so what will be your
responsibility being a business analyst
in IBM be part of international teams in
the design build test run faces of
customer projects from various
Industries and interesting business
domains this role as its clients and
projects in implementation of wide range
of application and business processes
communication with business owners and
end user to Define business requirement
and with development team to ensure
delivery to the agreed standard and
quality support testing in the
resolution of Defense learn and apply
processes and methodologies related
latest IIT Trends from both the JD we
can understand that business analysts
have to deal with clients a lot
so on an average 84 000 dollars per year
is the salary offered for a business
analyst working in IBM
and the final part is salary of a
business analyst
the average salary of a business analyst
for refresher is seventy thousand
dollars per annum in USA and experienced
is one hundred thousand dollars per year
an experience level you should be able
to evaluate and measure business
Frameworks and how they influence an
organization and their clients
coming to India the average salary of a
business analyst
for fresher ranges from 8 lakh per year
for experienced it can go as high as 15
lakhs per year and more also such as the
demand for business analyst all over the
world you are prepared to begin your
career in business analytics because you
have a better understanding of what
business analyst does their roles and
responsibility and steps involved to
become one the postgraduate program
business analysis by simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to equip
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as business analysts
this program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
enhance their business analytics skills
and Advance their career in the field so
this program covers various topics such
as business analysts Essentials project
management data analysis data modeling
and data visualization it also includes
Hands-On training in popular business
analyst tools such as you will see here
such as Microsoft Excel jira power bi
and many others upon completing the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
as a business analyst they will also
have access to Simply learns Career
Services which provides guidance and
support to help Learners transition into
the job market
overall the postgraduate program in
business analysts by simply learn is an
excellent option for individuals who
wants to enhance their business analysis
skills and Advance their career
perspective in this field so now next we
have business analytics boot camp by
simply learned this is an intensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business Analytics the program is
delivered online and is intended for
individuals who want to understand
business analysis comprehensively and
how it can be applied to real world
business problems this program covers
various topics such as data analysis
data modeling data visualization and
predictive modeling it also includes
Hands-On training in popular analysis
tools such as R python Excel and W the
business analytics bootcamp is designed
to provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in meaningful way it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insights and
recommendations to stockholder
effectively upon completion of the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
in the business analyst role access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
now let's see more about the business
analyst Masters program this Masters
program I simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to
provide Learners with a deep
understanding or business analysis the
program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
advance their career Prospectors in the
field of business analysis the program
covers various topics such as business
analysis Essentials project management
data analysis data modeling and data
visualization it also includes Hands-On
training in the popular business
analysis tools such as Microsoft Excel
Microsoft power bi R and python numpy
scientify to business analyst master
program is designed to provide Learners
with the skills and knowledge required
to succeed as a business analyst it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to effectively communicate with
stockholder manage projects and analyze
data upon completing the program
Learners will also get the certification
and the skills and knowledge required to
succeed in the business analysis role
which provides guidance and support to
help Learners transition into the job
market
the link will be in the description box
for all the courses next we have simply
learns business analytics for strategic
decision making certification program
which is designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business analysis and how it can be
applied in the real world business
problems the program is delivered online
as intended for individuals who want to
understand business analysts
comprehensively and Advance their career
this program is delivered by Indian
Institute of Technology roorkee this
program covers various topics such as
strategic analysis data modeling data
visualization predictive modeling and it
also includes Hands-On training in
popular analysis tools such as again
Microsoft Excel R and W the business
analysis for static decision making
certification program is designed to
provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in a meaningful way it
also focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate inside and
recommendations to stakeholder
effectively upon completing of the
program the learner will get the
certification by IIT roorkee and simply
learn we will also have the access to
Simply land's Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
the link will be in the description box
for this course also now we have simply
learned Sports graduate program in
business analytics in a comprehensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a deep understanding of business
analytics the program is delivered
entirely online and is intended for
individuals who want to advance their
career in the field of business
analytics the program covers the range
of topics such as statical analysis data
modeling data visualization machine
learning and Big Data so this program is
sponsored by Purdue University and you
will get the certification from IBM this
program covers a range of topics such as
statical analysis data modeling data
visualization machine learning and Big
Data it also includes Hands-On training
in popular analysis tools such as
Microsoft Excel ah programming Python
and tableau the postgraduate program in
business analyst is designed to provide
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst or data scientist it focuses on
developing the necessary skills to
effectively communicate insights and
recommendations to stakeholders manage
projects and analyze large volume of
data upon completion of the program
Learners will receive a postgraduate
program in data analysis certification
from Simply learn and the skills and
knowledge required to succeed as a
business analytics or data sensor
they will also have access to Simply
learns Career Services which provides
guidance and support to Learners
transition into the job market then try
giving shot to our simply learn Sports
graduate program in business analysis in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft the link in the description
box should navigate to the home page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered in this
session we will start with certain
exercises which we will perform in
Tableau in order to understand some
basic concepts
now in order to learn Tableau the basic
first step is to import a sample data so
in our case what we have done is we have
imported a sample Superstore which is in
Excel format a sample superstore.xl
which has three worksheets in it orders
people and returns so by importing this
data into Tableau first of all we will
create relationships between these
sheets in order to identify who all have
placed orders and how many people have
returned the orders we will do some
analysis on the orders placed by certain
set of people and Order returned by
certain set of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders
table the order sheet on the
relationship canvas here okay and you
can see the data sample data the first
100 rows over here
okay then now we need to create an inner
join with people's table between order
and people okay so if you see
it has automatically detected the field
names on which the inner join has to be
created so on the order side you have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people data
so if I close this box and go and check
the people's data
open
all right
so see the region and the person these
two columns from the people table have
now been
joined with the orders table right so it
means that these are the orders in a
particular region which has been placed
by
in this region
okay
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by customers
across multiple regions
south west of USA South Region west
region then you have a list of order IDs
which have been returned so basically
the order ID in the returns sheet
matches with those orders in the orders
table
and then you have the people
sheet in which you have region
and a person associated with that region
the sales person associated with that
region okay so basically when we are
combining joining orders with people we
are joining that
which orders
belongs to which region and who is the
sales person associated with it so what
we have done over here is we have made a
inner join means all the orders should
belong to particular region and that
region is in the people's sheet
and then in the second step
now we will make a
left join between returns and orders
not in a join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the order ID
okay so just edit this
click on left
and
select order ID as the join column now
what does left join means left joining
is that consider all the orders from the
orders table and only consider the
orders from the returns table which have
data means which are returned otherwise
show null for the order IDs which are
not returned so if you see this is the
these are the two columns from the
returns table and these are null because
this is relevant to the order IDs which
are not returned okay which has been
accepted by the customer but these are
the orders for which you see data in the
returned and Order ID column it means
that these have been returned
now with these joins in place please
save your book and now we have our
relations created in the
um
in the Tableau now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model
now we'll move to sheet1
okay
and first we will place
state
and person on the rows
sheet okay
then
I'll go to my
numbers and
put the profit or D so per state per
person how much profit I am making as a
company okay this is my goal to check
now sort by highest to lowest so
California is giving me the maximum
profit of seventy six thousand six three
hundred eighty one then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I have
listed my profit in descending order
now I can also check what are the number
of orders
placed
and check the distinct count
so out of 120 out of the total orders of
127 okay so this is the number of total
number of orders which have been
returned for California is 127.
it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as per
the revenue as per the profit and this
is the details of the orders which have
been returned per state
so if you see for connected for a
cancers there are zero returns
so you can also extract data
table to refresh his orders and identify
new rows using order date so as and when
new data is being added you can
refresh it now say extract
and now you can save this information
profit
by state
and click save so this is the extraction
of this particular report which is
possible in tableau
so this is the first exercise which we
have completed for
reviewing and analyzing the profit per
state highest to lowest and within that
per state what are the number of orders
which have been returned by all the
customers the distinct count of order
IDs which have been returned
now let's start our second exercise on
creating calculated fields in tableau
now in this exercise we will be doing
certain
activities like we will be creating a
set to show the states which have more
than 100 customers then we will be
creating a calculated field to show an
average sales per customer okay then we
will create a calculated feed to show
the sales goals and then show emerging
and developing stage so these are the
four kpis which we have to derive
now the first thing we have our sample
Superstore data already imported and the
relationships created in a join with
people and left join with returns
now we have our sheet 2 in which we will
create the states a list of states which
has more than 100 customers
so what we have to do is we have to
click right click on the customer name
and click create set
okay
now we have to give the name as states
with 100 plus customers
and then go to the condition tab
select by field
and then apply condition as
count of customer name
greater than equal to
and click
ok
now we have this set created states with
100 plus customers
now to determine average sales by
customer we have to now create a
calculated field
so go to the analysis and click on
create calculate field
okay
now name it as
average
sales per customer
and now we will say average
we will use a
foreign
that per customer we are using a level
of definition function include which
means that per customer what is my
average sales right we've already used a
function aggregated function called
average so we are saying per customer
give me the total and then give me the
average per customer so we're going to
click ok
now create another calculated field you
can also create from here
and name is as name it as sales goal
now in this we are going to type the
formula if
minimum
States
with 100 plus customers equal to true
then
sum of
sales
into 1.3
else
average sales per customer into
100 so me we are saying that
if the customer belongs to the set of
states with 100 plus customers then the
sales Target should be
1.3 times the actual sales as of today
else it should be 100 of the average
sales per customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging
or developing state
if distinct count
of customer name
is greater than equal to 100
then
the state is tagged as developing state
else it is called as
emerging state
okay so we have now
three calculated Fields average sales
per customer emerging or developing
State and sales goals
now we will use this in our reporting
so we will drag sales goal under the
columns
and then I'll drop my state
so now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or not
then add your customer name
make the measure as count distinct
and make it as discrete
okay so if you see this
we have the count of customers per state
and the
the sales goal
for that particular state
and now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want
which is there per state
now go to show me and select
this particular chart
bullet graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales access and select
swap reference line fields
now from your left hand panel drag and
drop emerging or developing straight on
the color panel
okay so a merging state is the orange
one and the developing state is the blue
one
and save the sheet as
developing and the emerging States
so if you see this it's an emerging
State because its count is less than the
customer count is less than 100
its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is 19511 okay
so now this is a developing State its
count is greater than equal to 100 and
its sales goal and its sales is exactly
the same it matches so that's why you
are saying the bar and the blue bar is
ending exactly where the vertical bar is
so what we are trying to depict is that
whether the state is going Beyond its
Target sales goal or it's behind it
and you can see that using this
particular vertical bar like for example
Michigan its sales goal is 71 952 but
its actual sales is seven six seven two
seven zero average sales so that's why
it is be above its Target
and it's a developing state
because it has more than 100 customers
so you can even sort
by the count of
the uh customers higher to lower so all
your developing state will group from at
the top and the emerging States Will
Group at the bottom
or you can sort by
the sales goal
so the orange bar is the sales goal or
the blue bar so depending what sales
goal
has been
derived for each state
hello and welcome to this new session on
tableau now in this session we will talk
about how to prepare dashboards and how
to Interlink reports within the
dashboard
so in order to start this session we
will first create couple of reports and
then include them in the dashboard and
then link them together
so for this session
as usual we are using the sample
Superstore data set for our example
now first we will create a report where
we are gonna
show profit by region per region
so first we will drag the region
in the rows column and we will get all
the regions and
state
so we have all the states per region in
our report now and then we will drag
sales
and profit
so now we have our sales and profit
measures the column level
now just also drag now the region to the
color section so now we have each region
colored
the entire sales and profit per region
is distinguished by the different colors
Central is south and west
now
click on the
colors
now we want to show the labels using the
marks card okay so we want to show the
region
okay so we need to include the show the
marks labels just a second
so enable the labels
say show Mark labels
okay
so you have on the left this is the
profit and this is the total sales now
rename
this sheet as region and state analysis
report
okay
now let's create another worksheet
now in this sheet just drag the state
on the
marks card now automatically Tableau
will detect that you know you have
dropped a particular State and we have
the states of United States so it has
identified the state names and showed
you the identifiers of the states on the
map and automatically
identified the latitude and longitudes
which are generated by Tableau and given
you the markers on each and every state
now drag the sales measure to the color
panel
okay so now this is sales per state in
the color scheme with the color scheming
then now Drag The Profit to the size
so now each state you have the color the
profit and the sales
now you can edit the colors and you can
select
a particular scheme of colors and say
apply and okay so now you are able to
distinguish
the colors on the state
now after this
just rename the sheet as
profit by state
report
now create let's create another report
now in this report drag the subcategory
to the column section
and
sales and profit measures in the
rows
okay
now click on the right click on the sum
profit pill and check dual access
now click right click on the profit
access and say synchronize access
now select some sales from the card
marks card and change the notation as
bar
and for profit change the notation as
line
so now this is a fair display of
sub category wise
sales and profit representation that
these are the sales and what is the
profit
now go to the marks all marks and drag
the category section
the
category section as the tooltip
okay so for each and every bar or line
item you should now see the category
also
save your report
and
rename this now report as sales
by and profit by sub category report
now let's create a new dashboard
now the reports which we have just now
created first our dashboard size let's
make it as automatic
okay then
let's show the dashboard title click
click on the dashboard title
now drag the reports which you have
created
profit by state
sales and sub category report
and region and
okay so you have all your three reports
in a single dashboard now
profit by state sales and profit by sub
category and region by and state
analysis report now we will link these
reports so go to dashboard
click on actions
add an action called new filter
select Source sheet in the source sheet
dashboard 2
only select region and state analysis
report
and in the Target sheet just deselect
region and state analysis
on the source sheet keep the Run action
on select and
click
ok
now whatever state you select over here
that particular state will be used as a
filter across both these reports so it
means in North Dakota you have all these
category subcategories being sold and
their Associated profit and on the map
profit by Straight report you can see
the North Dakota State being highlighted
or only selected and the relevant profit
and sales
okay so here is the total profit in
sales in the profit by state report and
in this sales and profit by sub category
report you have the breakup of the
profit and sales across the categories
similarly you can select any other state
and automatically the
filters will get applied automatically
see this Marine Main
okay
so with this we cover our example of how
to create multiple reports and then
connect them
or encapsulate them in a single
dashboard for a single view across all
these reports then try giving shot to
our simply learns postgraduate program
in business analysis in collaboration
with Amazon Google and Microsoft the
link in the description box should
navigate to the home page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered
today we are going to talk about power
bi what are its features what are the
basic advantages of using a
visualization tool like power bi and we
will talk about how to install powerbo
bi and other features it provides and
the basic setup
so let's discuss what's in it for us
today
now we will first talk about why power
bi you know why it's a popular tool and
what problem it solves what is power bi
uh and what are the primary features of
power VI uh which you can use in your
day-to-day data analytics visualizations
creating fancy reports creating
meaningful intelligent reports uh for
your organization for your personal use
for crunching numbers for generating
reports real time Etc
now the most popular tool for power bi
is the power bi desktop uh I'll show you
certain uh aspects of power bi desktop
and then I'll show you the steps how to
install power bi desktop on your machine
and then definitely power bi desktop is
a free tool provided by Microsoft but
then you can also subscribe for an
Enterprise version which is primarily
used by Enterprises for publishing their
data so we'll see the difference and
then overview of our dashboards which
can be created uh you know what kind of
dashboards can be created in power pi
so this is the agenda for us today
now why power bi so generally uh you
know visualization tools reporting tools
are required in order to create and
prepare and analyze meaningful data it
could be a data for an organization it
could be a social media platform data it
could be a data from iot devices but
something which needs to be analyzed and
some intelligent inferences and data
mining has to be done on top of it now
imagine there is today we are in a world
where terabytes of data and information
is getting generated on an instantaneous
basis on minute-by-minute basis so it
becomes very essential to churn out
something meaningful something
intelligent out of it in the market
there are a lot of other tools which are
available like clicks all tricks Tableau
and power bi so power bi is a Microsoft
product which is one of the most popular
products and it comes as a free to
download product Microsoft power bi
desktop which is available and I'll show
you a couple of ways how you can install
it on your machine but why power bi is
popular is because it provides a lot of
out of the box features drag and drop
features which we will talk about in our
subsequent sessions and you know classes
but today's session is primarily focused
on giving you guys an introduction on
what is the purpose of power bi and what
all problems it solve uh in the in the
real world so power bi allows you to
view analyze and visualize huge
quantities of data and the data could be
in any format Excel CSV text or it could
be a direct connection to a database
like SQL MySQL Azure Oracle anyone IBM
db2 so it supports n number of uh you
know data types or data sets and it's
very powerful in terms of data
connectivity so it uses powerful
compression algorithms to import and
cache the data within the dot pbix file
so it's as convenient as a simple
software if suppose you import the data
and then you prepare a report and then
you can easily share the reports with
your peers or someone who's
co-developing with you either through
Power bi cloud services or even you can
share the pbix file in an email
or through any other means and you can
share the data set with the concern and
they can then work on the report
independently so there are different
ways there is no uh kind of a limitation
for you know working on power bi there
are multiple ways and it is very fast it
is the most fast uh tool to work with
Excel because definitely Excel is also a
Microsoft Technology so it works very
fast on Excel based data and gives you
numbers and Reporting at a very high
speed
so now once you have imported the data
power bi allows you to model the data
allows you to work intelligently on the
data it allows you to model data in a
way that if you are importing data from
multiple Excel sheets importing data
from multiple tables you can easily
create a relationship between those
tables or data sets in power bi and then
create visually appealing reports
meaningful reports as I've been
emphasizing and make sense out of that
data no data in silos is of any use data
in Silo means a single worksheet or a
single data set will not churn out any
meaningful information until unless you
basically join it clubbit merge it Union
it append it with some other data sets
because a single data set will never be
able to hold that much amount of
information which is generally required
for a you know important report
so it has easy drag and drop
functionality with features that allow
you to copy all formatting across
similar visualizations so just like in
Microsoft Excel we use format painter to
copy the format of one cell to another
similar features very very similar to
excel products or Microsoft product they
have provided that if you have applied a
a particular thing on a report you can
easily replicate that on any other
report the font uh the header size the
background color you don't need to do it
again and again so there's a lot of
reusable features which are also
available
okay now
as I said Excel is a Microsoft product
power bi is a Microsoft product so they
have intercompatibility you can publish
data from Excel to power bi now with the
latest developments and enhancements
as of today pixel has also plugged in a
new feature called Power pivot which
I'll uh show you later down the line but
that also allows you to do a quick
analysis no you can't create of course
complex reports or uh fancy reports like
power bi but Power pivot allows you to
create you know quick measures quick
functions quick calculations on your
data quickly only in Excel so it's an
Excel plugin but whereas you know you
can power bi is also compatible with
Excel so when you create a report in
power bi it gives you inbuilt feature to
export your power bi report into Excel
format directly you don't need to do any
programming for it also
you can easily publish when you publish
your power bi reports it allows you to
give some inbuilt intelligence of
analyzing your reports in Excel and it
gives you all those of all those
features of exporting your power bi
reports into Excel which is not
available in any other tool or otherwise
those tools have to create plugins
create add-ins and probably they might
charge for it but Power bi comes with
lot of out of the box features which are
very very helpful for analyzing data in
Excel and vice versa
Azure Cloud now Azure itself again is a
Microsoft cloud Tech stack so using
power bi with Azure allows you to
analyze and share large volumes of data
so Azure basically Azure database or
Azure Cloud servers are meant to hold
huge amount of data and power bi allows
you to have seamless connection you can
easily connect to Azure data Lake
you can reduce the time it takes to get
insights and increase collaboration
between business analysts data engineers
and data scientists so azure
data Lake becomes the central focal
point where all your analysts Engineers
can keep working on on the centralized
piece of data and churn out their
reports data scientists primarily job is
to keep the data in a structured way
optimized way optimize the input output
operations disk operations and memory
utilization so that the reports also get
churned out in a faster manner so every
uh you know every person has their own
role in order to give a quick
refreshable report a quick rendered
report any report which is taking huge
amount of time to get rendered will not
eventually be used by the business users
because then it does not solve the
purpose the report should be fast
reports should have uh you know
appropriate filters slices and dices you
should be able to you know create the
reports or dynamically or you should be
able to analyze visualize the data
dynamically so all those visualization
features are available in power bi and
it works seamlessly either it is small
data or huge data it allows that you to
work on those kind of data in a seamless
fashion
right so this is just a very uh quick uh
example of how our typical dashboard
looks like dashboard is nothing but you
know you have clubbed couple of multiple
reports on a single page and you know if
you change a filter uh a single filter
on the page all the reports will honor
that filter and the numbers will change
accordingly so if you see the in this
example there is a filter or a drop down
or product ID product name employee name
or supervisor or a date range so
whatever date range or filter you will
apply all the reports on this dashboard
will get changed based on the filter you
have selected so power bi allows you to
get insights from data and turn insights
into action to take data driven business
decision and that is the ultimate goal
of any visualization tool that is the
purpose for which visualization tools
are bought
uh and purchased by the organizations
and data is fed into them
Now power bi fetches data from Factory
sensors social media sources to get
access to real-time Analytics so that
you are always ready to make timely
business decisions so so basically there
is a a feature of live connection or cut
off data connection so either you can
work on data which is deciding on a
machine and you can just work on the
cutoff data like for example it's
there's a data which is available for
sales 2017 2018 and you're just working
on a historical data it's a cut off data
or it could be possible that you want to
be connected live uh to a real-time iot
based sensor based data or social media
data like Twitter Facebook feeds or you
know you're connected to live Google
worksheets that is also possible you
just need to publish your Google sheet
for a public domain embed that you are
into Power bi and then whoever updates
that Google sheet automatically the
power bi report will also start honoring
and consuming the new data which is
added in the uh Google sheet so all
those kind of real-time streaming
analytics is also possible and that is
one big feature and very important
feature of power bi which is widely used
and has a very huge uh you know Market
acceptance and Market utilization
now what is power bi
power bi is a business analytics service
provided by Microsoft that lets you
visualize your data and share insights
right so earlier
you know uh
Microsoft used to have a technology
called ssas now they have replaced
actually ssas and SSRS with power bi so
basically you can use power bi on the
data which is there in your Excel or any
other data source and the power bi
service or power bi desktop basically
creates a connection to those data sets
and import it cache it and give you a
handle to it in order to work with it so
you can create these fancy meaningful
visualizations like for example there's
a geographical map if you are importing
data for a country or a continent or a
region power bi will automatically
detect that it's a geographical
information and give you a map with
latitude longitude information and you
just need to plot your uh your numbers
on the map either you can use bubbles or
either you can use triangles or whatever
data structure you want to use but all
the mapping will be available
geographically then you can create pie
charts which is shown in this
visualization you can create dream maps
you can create cards where you know you
can highlight the most important numbers
like sales total sales of your company
across all the regions or the growth
chart or the month on month uh you know
sales of your organization or number of
total number of products or units sold
so whatever is important and to be
highlighted for the management to take
any meaningful decision or any insights
you want to share power bi visualization
tool the power bi visualization uh
uh chart allows you to drag and drop and
create wonderful reports okay
so what are the features of power bi so
power bi desktop is something a
standalone tool which you need to
install on your machine it allows you to
build reports by accessing data easily
you do not need Advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report though yes it is beneficial that
if you know some SQL programming
analytical programming or you are aware
of advanced features of any analytical
tool that might help you but that's not
a showstopper you can easily build
reports in quick turnaround time without
needing any technical background you
just need to have some analytical uh
mindset and you can create uh Savvy
visualization and you know analytical
reports
stream analytics as I mentioned you can
create a live connection uh with any
kind of data it could be iot it could be
media social media it could be Google
Docs it could be uh you know any other
kind of uh you know live connection it
could be a live database connection
itself so any insertions or updations or
deletions happening will automatically
reflect in your report
yes multiple data sources and that has
to be the primary criteria for any tool
to be popular if any visualization tool
is limited to certain data sets then you
know it will not be highly acceptable in
the market
and custom visualizations right so as I
showed you certain uh examples in the
past in the previous presentation uh
that feature is very important because
someone might want to look the kpis look
at the kpis from a different perspective
some management might want to look at
the kpis from a different perspective so
you need to you need to have that
capability to create different
visualization from the same data set now
let's take a look at how
to install power bi desktop on your
machine
so basically what you need to do is
you need to go to this URL
power bi dot microsoft.com en US desktop
okay
and you need to just
enter this
now you can download it for free so just
click over here
and
it will open Microsoft store so
basically now what Microsoft have done
in the latest operating systems is that
when you are trying to download you can
actually directly go to the Microsoft
store
and search for Power bi
so let's wait for a couple of seconds
right here so power bi desktop in
Microsoft store for me it's already
installed so it's asking me to open it
I'll open it in a while but for you for
anyone who is not installed he will see
the button of install over here and it
will automatically install in your
machine and then you can easily go and
open power bi desktop now if I click
open over here
now this is the
uh UI of the power bi desktop
I'm not going to go right now in
creating reports right away we will talk
about that in a subsequent session with
sample data sets and we will cover the
features of power bi desktop one by one
but this is what it is this is the whole
tool of power bi which is having the
visualization pane all the different
visualizations are you know can be
created from this pane
then this is the pane which allows you
to select the data data fields then
there is a report view data View and
relationship view the data model view
where multiple relationships you can
create you can view the data in the grid
of the tables which you will create and
the reports so you can create multiple
reports on multiple Pages you can keep
adding pages either you can drag create
multiple reports on a single page and it
will become a dashboard or you can
create separate independent reports on
the single page
and these are the menu options which we
will talk about how you can change color
scheming you can do data modeling you
can create new reports and you can also
transform data which is the biggest
feature extract transform and load the
data apply different logic changing data
types massaging the information creating
new joins appending the data you know
adding new columns etc etc uh we that is
what you can do in transform data so
this itself is a whole different world
it's a dedicated topic so we will talk
about that in our subsequent sessions so
what's in it for us today we will be
learning how to connect to data
different data types data files like
Excel PDF then what are the different
data importing modes and then I will
also show you practically different sets
how to import them in power bi and use
it for your visualization purpose now
what are the steps to connect to data so
now we will go directly into Power bi
and try to import one by one few most
commonly and popularly used data sets
which are most commonly used in a
day-to-day activity rest of course there
are power bi supports n number of data
sources but we will do something
practical on the most popular ones so
let's let's open our power bi
now this is my power bi and first I want
to show you that how can I import data
directly from a web page and import the
data now it is asking for a URL in order
to import data so what I have done is I
have created a Google Excel sheet with
simple data with rows and columns and
what I have done is I have shared this
sheet as published to web
okay so you just need to say publish to
the web the link as web page and
say done it's it's automatically
published and say link so copy the link
which you have published on the web copy
this link
and then go back to your tableau
paste that link over here and click ok
Now power bi will try to establish a
connection with this Google doc sheet
because it's published on the web
you need to wait for a while while it is
reading
okay now it has read one of the HTML
tables so I'll select this one now you
can see it has it is showing me a
preview of the table which is there on
my
Google sheet right it has 11 rows so it
has all showed all the 11 rows so now I
can go and transform this data because I
can see my headers are there starting
from the second row so there's an
opportunity for me to transform the data
so I'll go and transform it so that it
looks clean
okay so first is I need to remove the
first row which is the
null row remove the top rows
okay and then I need to use the first
row now as a header so you just click
this option use first row as headers
that's it so now if you see my row ID
order ID order date ship date all my
data is now ready so I can say close and
apply
click apply changes
now this is an example of web data
import you can go and preview your data
right now the biggest advantage of this
data connection is that it's a live data
so for example I insert another row
let me change the order ID
some some I've sub change some basic
stuff and I
it's Auto saved
Ctrl s now I'll go to my tableau and
I'll refresh
now you can see as I refreshed my
power query editor I click refresh all
and I got my new row which is there in
the live data I got that fetched from my
okay I got that row the row number ID
number 12 so I have to say close and
apply
now you can see the new row the row
number 12 is now available in my new
data set in the data set because it's a
live connection it's a live connection
with the web based Google sheet okay so
this is one
important way in which you can import
data
now let's try to import data from a text
file
now I have already prepared our text
file called
sub categories Dot txt
now let me just open it in a notepad now
it's a very plain simple file tab
separated file in which you have product
sub category ID subcategory name and
product category key so basically to
which product category this particular
sub product belongs to right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go back to
my get data option
and I am going to select text slash CSV
option
and I'm gonna select option mod product
subcategories Dot txt
okay so now power bi has identified that
it's a tab delimited file it has
recognized the headers
Etc right and I can now directly load
this file
okay
so now once the data is imported in
power bi it is like
irrelevant to me it's a composite data
in in Port I'm doing right so in my
presentation when I am talking about
importing data there are different
importing modes right import our data
import can happen through different ways
okay
one is direct query mode in which I
create a live connection to the database
which I'll also show you uh using MySQL
and Ms SQL server and also you can do a
composite mode in which you can have
data imported from Excel plus you can
have direct query modes so you can have
multiple uh modes to connect and create
a composite data model and that's what
we are doing right now in our practical
so what we are doing over here is one we
have imported data from the web second
we have imported data from a text table
now after doing text now our next task
is to import from CSV let's try another
one so now I have imported product
subcategory now I'll import
a CSV file so again I'll choose the
option Text slash CSV and now in this
CSV file let me open this CSV file and
show you what it is it
so this is a list of all my products
product key products sub category Key
Products stock keeping unit Etc a simple
CSV file and I'm gonna import that
okay so now it is identified the
delimiter is comma rather than a tab and
it has already recognized the headers
correctly so I load it
okay so now my products are there
product subcategories are there for
product categories now what I have done
is I have created a Excel mode now so
now Excel I am using to import my
product category
so now I have to click on the option of
import data from Excel and I'll say
product categories
select the sheet load
and now so my products product
categories product subcategories do with
different uh data storage types but
still now the data is imported into
Power bi is a composite data model now
another very important data type which
you can import is the PDF also right so
what I have done is I have created a PDF
called customers my customers data is
lying in a PDF so what I've done is I've
created a PDF
which has data for some columns are
there like you know customer key prefix
first name last name birth grade marital
status gender email address annual
income total children etc etc so this is
the data set which I have created in PDF
so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to select PDF now
and import customers.pdf
and see it has recognized my table on
page one which I am going to load
okay
you can rename this as PDF
table
okay so this basically these are the
different type of
data
types we have imported PDF Excel text
CSV and web page
now let's take a look at another
interesting data set which you want to
import is the my SQL Server data set
so what I have done is I've already
installed MySQL server on my local
instance and there's already a schema of
SQL live tutorial over there and I have
certain tables already
prepared over there like Department
employee Etc so my goal is now to import
this data or create a live connection
with this data set
now in order to import
my SQL database Connection in power bi
you need to First
download a
connector MySQL power bi connector so
you need to go to this link
and then click on download and install
the MySQL connector based on the
operating system you have you click on
download and install it
after you have done this go back to
Power bi
and then give
the IP address of the database in my
case it's there in this local machine
and the schema which I want to import is
SQL live tutorial so I'll give the name
click connect
okay now it's connected so now it is
asking me which particular tables you
want to create a connection with I am
choosing department and employee
and I'm just loading them
okay so now this is the exact data which
is there in the employee and Department
in MySQL okay so this is one example of
how to create connectivity between power
bi and MySQL now I want to do the same
thing using
SQL Server Microsoft SQL Server so I
have also installed Microsoft SQL server
on my machine
and I have used the SQL Express so this
is the name of my server so which I'll
copy the server name and
go to get data
select SQL Server
and for now database is optional I can
say direct query click ok
now it is showing me what all tables I
can import so in my SQL Server tutorial
in my SQL Server I have
I have these three tables customers
employee attrition Olympic events so I
can use probably the customers one which
is
now you can see this is the data the
customer's data which is lying in my SQL
Server okay so I can preview it and load
it
so now you can you can preview the data
in uh Power bi that is this is the data
so I can rename his customer strong
Ms SQL
and this is from
MySQL
and
okay so now
this is not the only data
sets you can import now if you take a
look at the options which power bi gave
what different type and variations of
data it can it has compatibility to
import from
okay so we can just take a look at the
categorization on the left hand side
first there are five ways like Excel
text XML Json is also possible you can
evenly directly import an entire folder
and within the folder whatever uh data
types of files are there it will detect
it PDF power key or even SharePoint
folder which is itself Microsoft uh
technology then different kind of
databases SQL server and MySQL we just
saw but it's not only limited to this
you can connect to Microsoft Access
ssas Oracle database IBM db2 postgres
site base teradata and then sap
databases Amazon redshift Impala vertica
Snowflake and N number of databases
which are there in the market today
Amazon
Etc
then it also allows you to connect with
its own power platforms power bi
platforms data mods power bi data flows
dataverse Etc
Azure there are different kind of
storage
mechanisms in Azure and Azure itself is
a Microsoft Technology uh so it has a
compatibility of a lot of azure uh based
data storages like Azure SQL database
blob storage uh Azure data breaks right
Azure HD insights path so if you have
those kind of services running on your
observed cloud services you can even
import them over here
now online services like you know you
have erps running uh or some data which
is shared on the internet if you want to
import it uh that is also possible
through certain products uh Dynamics 365
Microsoft Exchange online Salesforce
Google analytics Adobe analytics GitHub
LinkedIn sales if you want to do some
analysis of some social networking
you know feeds that also you can import
then other miscellaneous are also their
web-based hive R script python script
which is something to import get data
from uh Google Sheets like we store one
example in our video right now so there
are multiple options available
now once you have imported the data
which is relevant to you
um in our subsequent sessions we will
see how to create relationships but just
giving you a glimpse that whatever data
you are importing power bi Auto detects
certain relationships and it will create
for you but then you can go and manually
also change so this is the composite
data model which is getting created in
the back end while you are importing the
data you can easily go and manage these
relationships either keep them as is you
can delete and create new ones manually
so there is no limitation in that
so this is what we have witnessed we
have imported data from different files
types data types and then you know we
have tried once it is imported into uh
Power bi then there is no limitation of
how you use it you can create
visualization across different data sets
and then create your
standard reports
so this is the example of importing data
from web importing data from a database
from a PDF
and then once you have data you can
shape and combine data you can basically
do whatever whatever transformation you
want to do you want to make joins merge
the data so for example if we go back to
our power bi and if I go back to my
transform data section
now as I have now different data sets
available with me I have I can do any
kind of you know operation
transformation on the data right uh so
like I showed you I uh upgraded the
header row because one of the imported
data was not showing the header
correctly uh or this columns like this
exactly one column is extra I can remove
the column
right all those Transformations whatever
I do in the back end gets captured in
the applied steps section right
this is the customer data you can create
uh you can merge it you can append it uh
you know with other data sets right
looks for example I want to create a
merge data set of my categories and sub
categories so I can say mer selectors
two data sets and say merge queries as
new
and
I can select product categories and
product subcategories select
product category key on both the side
and then they do a left Auto Zone so
whatever product categories are there
I'll get the subcategories associated
with it and I'll create a new table
which will have
now I have the table which has the
category and the subcategory and
subcategory in one table itself so I can
rename it now to as
category
sub category
table it's a it's a merge basically it's
a join between category and subcategory
and now I have a common table right and
I can close and apply
so imagine I have created a new table
which is imported created from one data
set is which is Excel page another data
set which is text based
see this category subcategory table so
now I can use it
the way I want
in my visualization reports so that's
what the presentation says right that
once you have uh the imported data you
can shape you can combine you can adjust
you can do whatever transformation you
want to do and create your visualization
okay so what topics we are going to
cover today we are going to talk about
different types of data modeling and the
most important part
and aspect of data modeling is the
cardinality the cardinality which you
basically decide after reviewing the
nature of data and after you've imported
it what kind of cardinality you have to
basically highlight right and there are
different type of cardinalities which
you might have heard earlier also if you
are from PL SQL background like one is
to one one is too many Etc we will we
will talk about that
now what are the different types of data
modeling now dimensional data modeling
is one of the most popular and most uh
you know widely used uh modeling in
dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers
Etc that will change less frequently as
compared to the sales transactions
because transactions are happening every
day every minute so sales is a more fast
changing data set in dimensional
modeling which is in the terminology of
data is also called as a fat and
customer store product which are like
more of static data and less changeable
data is sometimes called a diamond
patient so this is a typical dimensional
data model which is typically used uh
sometimes right and then there is
another model which is relational model
this is a typical model which we have
been using in database design like you
know primary key foreign key
relationships so for example you have a
customer who has purchased a product so
probably he might have the customer
might have the details of the product
which is processed and you will make a
join between customer and product table
and even you can make a join between
product or product type or customer or
product type customer table will also
have a key to the product type so this
is less conducive for reporting but it
is more of a transactional relational
model but of course this is also
feasible but from the power bi
perspective when we talk about reporting
and visualization this is the most
extensively used dimensional data model
and this is what we are going to see in
our example now so what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna show you certain data sets
first we will prepare and create certain
offer data sets and then we will Import
in our sample power bi and then slowly
slowly we will create the relationships
now one important thing which you need
to understand that in power bi if you go
to Power bi there is an option that that
power bi Auto detect new relationships
after data is loaded and import
relations from the data source on first
load so for example if you are importing
the data from a database where you have
already defined the primary keys and the
foreign key relationships so uh that is
the first option which power bi will
Auto detect and secondly if suppose you
are importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
power bi detects a common column key
columns it will auto detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship
menu manage relationship menu in power
bi which I'm going to show you okay so
if I open a power bi and this is where
the option lies go to file
go to options and setting options
data load
and these are the two options which are
by default check you can uncheck it and
auto and manually prepare relationships
there's no limitation to that but if you
uh keep it checked then power bi will do
its job to detect the relationships okay
now coming to the next important factor
cardinality
now before I start playing around with
my data and start showing you certain
relationships it's very important to
understand these four types of
cardinalities one is many to one right
so basically
many to one means that many orders
contain data of One customer so per
order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one-to-man relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many-to-one
relationship
okay
second other cardinality is one is to
one one is to one relationship is only
applicable when you are saying it's an
extension of the current table so for
example in one table you have employee
details and you are extending the
details of the employee in another table
like employee address employee ID so
that is like one is to one there is no
multiple records of a single employee in
the address table only one employee ID
exists right
now one is too many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one okay so
in customer table only one customer
record exists per customer and one
customer can place many orders for
multiple products and can also have
multiple delivery addresses so that way
this is a typical one is too many
relationship we will be seeing this
example also in our sample data set
and last is the many-to-many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you practice practically and in our
case we will see that like for example
you have placed an order for a
particular product uh you know but there
are multiple fulfillments which has
happened so suppose you made order for
10 products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically you the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order
ID might have a multiple fulfillments
for the same order ID so there will be a
multi many to many relationship which
I'll show you practically so now with
this background let's
start importing our data now the first
important thing which we need to import
is the
Master data so first I'll import all my
master Dimensions which is uh which I'm
going to you know use in my example so
first is the customers table customers
data
so this is the customer details the
customer key prefix first name last name
birth date marital status and gender
some redundant columns are also present
but we'll remove it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes
okay so now this is my customers data
with the relevant columns and the key
per customer customer key
now there's no relationship in this
model right now right because only
single table is there and the associate
data is only imported now let me also
import my another important master table
is the products
select the products data product key
product sub category product SKU product
name model name product description
color size so just see all the relevant
information only specific to the product
is available so I'll import it
okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales table
now I I'm assuming that power bi have
Auto detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
take that check box now let's see what
power bi what relations power bi has
Auto detected let's first say check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click this
join now what it has done is it has
created a join of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
place many orders right and that is that
it is detected by the quality of the
data and the data sampling which power
bi has done you can also reverse this
relationship here I can select customers
and I can select sales now it has become
one too many so that you can also do
manually so that is what I said whatever
power bi is detected it is up to the
description of power bi internal uh
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's
change the relationship so one is too
many means from One customer and many
sales orders
similarly let's see what has happened at
the product side
of the relationship
similarly power bi many sales orders for
one product you can for simplicity's
sake you can say products
sales
product key is the join now just focus
one more thing please also see the the
column on which the join is is the grade
column grade out column product key is
also here and product key is also there
and it is what we wanted so one is too
many relationship from product to sales
table and act
now looks fine this is something which
is looking logical and probably now we
can
proceed further to create a report
now let me explain the cross filtering
with an example
now for example I want to check in a
report
that what is the count of products which
uh which a particular customer has
ordered
okay so what I'll do is I'll select the
product count of product name
now if you see
and for each customer in front of each
customer name the count is coming as 293
293 it is getting repetitive because
because there is a one-way filter
Direction filter between customers and
sales and sales and products right so
this join
is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go here
I'll first open my sales table
we can also open it here let's make
click it says okay now if I click OK you
can see the single arrow is changed to
Double Arrow it means it's a it's a both
site filter
So when you say a both side filter it
means that implicitly within power bi
you can imagine that all the product
columns now will get appended because of
both ways filter you have applied and if
you go to your report now see the change
of the numbers now for T20 so the total
count of products across all my
customers come out to be 293 now the
report looks uh correct if I change the
relationship from back to single between
product and sales then you can't make a
join between customers and product
basically you can't derive the product
count from the product table see this
if you have to live with it then you
would have to go to the sales table get
the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct okay
so if you want a report in which you
want the count of product name
and even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the
direction of the filter which is from
single to both so this is a typical
example they where you want to use a
two directional filter
now let's proceed further and import
other data set in order to show you
another example
now I want to show you an example of
one is to
1.
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is there
so I'm loading the customer details now
you see it has Auto detected a one is to
one relationship
but what is the meaning of one is to one
means One customer key only has one
entry in customer details there is no
multiple entry so if you click this
button
it's a one is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now easily
associate a
email address with the first name you
will get one is to one
record
so now you can see that with one is to
one relationship
with the first name I have Associated
the email ID and for each email ID
there is a Associated first name method
so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count
so in this report what we have done is
uh if you click over here so the first
name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one relationship
and then
and if you drag
the customer key
report takes time to render and even if
you can
so this is the reporting output you have
the customer key first name associated
email address and the count of product
names uh which the customer has ordered
now this is an example of one is to 1.
now I want to show you an example of
many too many now for that I'll import
my
fulfillment data set
foreign
data set there is a column for
order number so basically what I'll do
is I'll drag order number from here to
here
okay so now what has
um
uh Power bi detected
I'll do one thing I'll select sales over
here
fulfillment over here and order number
to odd number
okay so it's a many-to-many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order now
many to many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for
both ways cross filter detection uh a
Direction but you can you can check that
but definitely uh Power bi shows a
warning that this relationship has
cardinality to many to many and this
should only be used if it is expected
that neither column contains unique
values okay so we know that fact that's
why we are accepting this relationship
as many to many because we know there
are multiple order numbers over here in
the sales table which are mapped to the
multiple order numbers in the
Fulfillment table we'll click ok
now you want to keep the uh
uh direction as both ways or One
Direction that is up to you the way you
want to map the report so I can double
click over here
and you can even click so now you can
select from which way single filter you
want from fulfillment to sales or sales
to fulfillment I'll prefer sales to
fulfillment and click ok
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to shortlist one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many too many
now if I show you further relationships
which you can keep on adding like for
example I have a uh the example of
territories
now in which particular territory the
sales was done
map it over here
okay so now it's a typical one is too
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you have
uh details of returns
now this is another transactional table
which is about the orders which have
been returned rather than being you know
returned by the customers so you have a
product key
uh so automatically power bi has
detected a relationship between the
product key and the product uh table
right and even if you can join the
territory key in which territory the
return has happened
right so mostly the most common
relationship which you will observe is
the one is too many because
as I told earlier the most common
relational model is the dimensional
model uh the static data the slow
changing Dimensions the scds are the
master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I
talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the territory stable sorry uh the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data model now so far what we have done
as per our last session is that we did
data modeling on the different data sets
which we had imported in power bi like
products sales data returns fulfillment
customer details uh and customer Master
data calendar details Etc so in the last
session we prepared a data model and
established the relationships between
these different and data sets like one
is to one one is too many many to one
one is to one Etc and we saw the
examples now once our relational model
is prepared our data model is prepared
now our next activity is to create
certain additional columns which we want
to derive basis the data which we have
imported
so for example I'll start with my
product data set now in my product data
set I want to introduce a column which
basically
categorizes that if any product which
has a color uh you know red black or
gray I am going to tag it as a colored
product rest I'm gonna say not a colored
product right so all these are like
example of byte type product skus so for
that now in order to introduce a new
column you just need to do what you need
to select the table in the data grid go
to the table tools and say new column
okay so column will get appended to the
rightmost part and you will start seeing
a uh formula section typical to like you
get in your Excel now I'm gonna say that
the name of my column is going to be
byte type color okay and I'm just
creating a if condition if
product
color
is equal to
black
okay
or
or if it is equal to red
or if it is equal to
Gray
then
say yes it's a colored product I'll say
no
okay so now you can see this is the
product color red and black they are
saying by type color Yes blue is no
multi is no etc etc so this is a classic
example of an if and else condition
based conditional column
okay so you can create such columns now
second column custom column which I want
to create is I'm going to call as
discount
now this is the pricing of my products I
want to associate certain discounts
which I am ready to give to my customers
this is the product category like what
is the pricing of the category again I'm
going to use make use of if else but in
a nested way so if I am saying if my
product
price is less than 100
then I will give
zero percent of
uh zero percentage of discount so 0 into
product price just to keep it consistent
now I'm seeing
else
if less than 100 and 0 else I'll check
again that
if
the price is
less than
500 then I am ready ready to give one
percent discount
on the
product price
else
I'll move further so like this I have
created a formula
so what I'm saying is if product price
is less than 100 give zero percent if it
is less than 500 then give one percent
less than 2 000 then 1.5 percent less
than three thousand then two percent and
otherwise else less than three thousand
if a two percent else three percent
right now after this column is created
now you can check right so this C the
product price for this particular
product it is less than 100 so that's
why there is no discount it is
uh between 100 to 200 then this has been
given a one percent discount so like
this all the discount column is now
calculated now this column is available
just like a regular column in my product
table
now after this I'll go to my sales table
now in sales table I want to
identify a
create a column called as cost
there is no product cost column over
here so that will be derived
so let's create a column
called as cost
and it is derived by order quantity
into now the cost of the product
is in the product table and I know I
have already created a relationship
between product and sales table
so I just need to select the product
cost column now only keyword which I
have to use in power bi is the related
keyword so this will pick up the
relation
and now for this particular sale order
the cost has already been derived so
this order number this is the cost for
which uh the product has is the costing
of the product for this particular order
you do
okay
now I'm gonna create another conditional
column over here called as
order status
I'm saying if
any order whose order quantity is
greater than 2
then for my organization it's an urgent
order
else it is a
normal order
oh sorry
mustard
so this is my
order status column and I have my order
quantity
urgent or normal
so any order which has order quantity
one is normal any order which is having
order quantity as greater than
2 is
urgent you can see this
so there's a this whole power bi
uh tabs and sheets allow you to also
review the data what you're doing so
it's very convenient
now
I have my sales data now what I want to
bring within the sales is my discount
column so here also I want to bring the
discount which I have created
so I'll say discount
[Music]
will be order quantity
into
related
product discount right so the discount
calculated column which I had created
under products I'll bring over here
now I am creating the order level
discount so if you see for this
particular order there's a 25 uh
uh you know for 25 rupee discount at the
cost is hundred thousand rupees okay
and what is the order price now so I
have taken the order cost the discount
now I have to create a column call as
price order price so that will be
again order quantity
into related
price which is per product
price and
okay so now I have the cost the discount
and the price right available with me
now I want to
calculate the total
uh
total revenue total profit and loss
right
per order how much
so first I'll calculate per order how
much revenue I am generating so now I
have to generate a column called as
Revenue
revenue is price
minus discount
so 1700 minus 25
1700 minus 25 2071 minus 42 and if I
want to calculate the profit per order
then it is
Revenue
Minus cost
okay so now you can see you know typical
custom columns calculated columns which
we have created are all playing around
with the number numeric values numeric
data primarily and trying to give
inferences into per order cost discount
per order price revenue and profit so
typical calculation columns which I have
prepared in front of you
now let's take a look at other different
variations of custom columns
I'll create certain columns for text
based custom columns calculated columns
using Text data so I'm now moving
towards my customer table in which I
have customer key prefix first name last
name birth date marital status and
gender
now I want to create a new column in
which I want to derive the age of each
customer as of today right so I'll use
another function a date function called
as
date div
now date div so I want the difference
between the birth date of the customer
and as of today
in years
okay so this customer as of today 68
year old one is 74 68 57 Etc so this is
one derivation of a calculated column of
age
let's take another example now this is a
text based column where I want to
derive the full name of the customer
now here I will say first
lowercase in lower case I'll concatenate
the prefix
then ampersand
space
ampersand
first name
Ampersand space
ampersand
last name
and closing brackets
Etc
full name
okay so this is an example of full name
in low cases
now another
calculated column conditional column at
the customer level
I want to identify a flag which says who
is my Target customer base is the
demographics shared over here Target
customer
so I'll say
if
the marital status is equal to
m
and
total children
hurry
and total children annual income
so okay so let me change the logic a bit
so marital status is M and age
is
less than
these customers are my Target customers
okay so I would say
yes
else no
see this
he is a marital status is married Logan
Diaz and age is less than 50 else
everyone so if I try to filter
so these are the my Target customers
69 out of 1178 so this is just a
conditional column but a logical
condition an example which I am trying
to highlight over here
okay now
let's look at certain calendar
date oriented columns calculated columns
very typical like now I have a simple
date column now I'll keep adding certain
columns which are you know which help
you which will help you understand how
we can uh
you know do some calculations on the
dates so like for example I want a date
which is 12 days after the current date
the date in the column so just simple 12
Days After
select the date and add 12.
now if you see the date format you can
go and change the format at the top
and if whatever you feel like like this
now see 12 days after first Jan 2015 is
13 Jan 2005. you can go and change the
format and other details
let me also show you if I go to my cost
and other columns I can go and change
the format this is like a currency cost
is currency so I can go and
select the
change the currency type and you can
even show the dollar value or whatever
currency type it is
so for numbers you can do currency or
text or dates you can select the format
so this is available at the column tools
level
now in customers
like we had our
column of full name so now what all
things are available format as text okay
data type text so very minimal options
are there with date you have options of
the date format
now next
I want a column which defines the expiry
date okay so eight months prior
to the expiry date within which is
coming up in eight months so I'll create
a column called as eight months expiry
and then there is a e date function I'll
use that I'll use my
date in the data set
comma I'll say eight so now this date
column will append eight months to my
actual date and again I can go and
change the format
correct
now another important column like I want
to know the date name
so I'll use a function called as
format
and I'll select my calendar date column
and I'll say give me the DDD
format of it so it will give me the day
name the day the day name of on that
particular date
next
years in between
so I want the years in between the
today's date and the date of my calendar
so equal to
D Def
the calendar date
comma today
comma year
end
seven years 2015 to 2022
then last date of the month
so if I want what is the last date of
this particular calendar month
I will use a function EO month which is
there and label in the
power bi so I'll say
last date of the month
equal to
e o month
then
just select the calendar CSV date
comma
0 in months and enter
change the format
then similarly start of the month
so I'll use a function called start of
month
so for for all January dates end of the
month is 31st Jan and start of the month
will remain 1st of January
change the format
foreign
next I want to know what is the weak
number of that particular date so now
there is an inbuilt function called
week number week num and just pass the
date and you will get
the weak number first week of the year
second week of the year Etc
now another very
good example is whether the weak
day is a weekday or a weekend right so
what is it's a weak type okay
so I'll check I'll put a if condition
and there is a function called weekday
and I'll pass the calendar
if it is less than 6
it means it's a weekday as it's a
weekend
so all Saturday
and Sunday D news will come as weekends
or else everything else will come as
weekly then try giving shot to our
simply learns postgraduate program in
business analysis in collaboration with
Amazon Google and Microsoft the link in
the description box should navigate to
the home page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered
hello and welcome to the lesson
formatting conditional formatting and
important functions in this lesson we
will learn about custom formatting how
to use conditional formatting and
formulas and Implement logical
statistical and mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above Target below Target and met Target
as a data set can be huge and complex
differentiating each value manually
would consume a lot of effort and time
here comes the Excel features such as
formatting and conditional formatting
which enables us to perform this task
easily
formatting as the name suggests helps us
to format the data using different
techniques making the data easy to read
in the required format and analyze them
the right formatting technique applied
to the worksheets can help the users
present the data efficiently conditional
formatting a type of formatting helps us
visually explore and analyze data detect
critical issues and identify patterns
and trends conditional formatting helps
to add patterns and Trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formula Etc
at times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set
Excel provides a large number of logical
statistical and mathematical functions
such as vlookup hlookup and if not rank
quartile and many more that can help the
users to perform calculations ranging
from basic to complex operations
these inbuilt functions help us to
manage data and perform descriptive
statistical analysis
Excel also offers a wide range of
important formulas that help to perform
many common tasks these formula may be
as simple as basic addition or it could
be a complex combination of inbuilt
excel functions
before going into details let us start
this lesson by defining the objectives
of the lesson
the worksheets appear more polished and
easy to read if proper formatting
techniques are applied to it
we can format the cells in Microsoft
Excel manually by selecting fonts font
color font size background colors and
borders we can also use numerous
predefined table Styles or quick styles
to quickly format a table automatically
this is the basic formatting in Excel
if these built-in functions do not meet
our needs or do not display the data in
the format that we require we can create
our own custom format in this topic we
will focus on custom formatting in Excel
let's say we want to display one million
five hundred and thirty two thousand as
1.53 M or the 1st of January 2016 date
with a weekday as the first Friday
January
2016. here we can use custom formatting
feature of excel let's see how we can
accomplish this in Excel
in this lesson we shall consider the
following fields from our master table
dates order ID
product salesman region number of
customers net sales and profit and loss
here in the given worksheet we have a
column named net sales
suppose we want to display the values of
net sales in terms of thousands for
example
7164 should be displayed at 7.16 k
select the entire column for net sales
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in the numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cells dialog box appears
from the category list select the type
as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number zero decimal zero zero
comma
open double quote capital K close double
quote
here number is the digit holder with
thousand comma separation
each comma after decimal 0 0 indicate
divide value by one thousand
the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places
the K component displays a literal K
character to denote thousands
here we can see the preview in sample
box the value shown is 7.16 K
finally click OK button to
the values in column net sales are now
displayed in terms of thousands
now let us consider another example of
date formatting
in the column dates we have a date value
written as 1st Jan 2012. we want to
display it as first Sunday Jan 2012.
first select the column containing dates
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cell dialog box appears
from the category list select the type
as custom
in the type text box enter DD Dash D D
Dash m m
y y
here d stands for date
m stands for month and y stands for year
the first 2dd is the date
the next four D D D D is for weekday say
Thursday
then mm is for the month in short form
and YY is for year
here we can see in the preview in the
sample box the value shown is one Sunday
Jan 12.
finally click on OK button
thus the custom formatting helps us in
changing the appearance of the cell
value according to our needs
a worksheet may contain thousands of
rows of data by simply examining the raw
information it would be difficult to see
patterns and trends conditional
formatting helps us visualize data that
make worksheets easier to understand it
quickly highlights important information
in a spreadsheet by using colors icons
and data bars it changes the appearance
of one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than 5000 color the cell yellow
by applying this rule we will be able to
quickly see which cells contain values
that are greater than 5000 let us
understand this with the help of
examples
consider the given sales table which
depicts the amount of sales done by each
salesman here we want to highlight the
duplicate order ID values
first select the order ID column
click Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over highlight cells rules and select
duplicate values
a duplicate values dialog box appears
select a formatting style from the drop
down menu in our example we will choose
green fill with dark green text click ok
here we can see that the conditional
formatting is applied to the column
order ID
Excel highlights all the duplicate cells
with green fill with dark green text
we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains
a date occurring and top slash bottom
rules all these rules work in the
similar format
Excel provides predefined styles to
quickly apply conditional formatting to
our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph
color scales color scales change the
color of each cell based on its value
each color scale uses a two or three
color gradient icon sets icon sets add
specific icon to each cell based on its
value
let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to apply the icon set rule
if sales amount is greater than 8 000
then a green arrow should appear in the
upward Direction
if sales amount is between five thousand
and eight thousand then show a yellow
arrow in the horizontal Direction
and if sales amount is less than five
thousand then show a red arrow in the
downward Direction
to perform conditional formatting select
the desired cells
click on Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over icon set rules and select the first
rule
again click on conditional formatting
select the option manage rules from the
drop down a conditional formatting rules
manager dialog box appears
go to Icon set Rule and select three
icon set rule
click on edit Rule and an edit rule
formatting dialog box appears
by default for three icon set rule Excel
uses the 67th percentile and the 33
percentile rule this means that it shows
a green arrow for values greater than 67
percent
yellow arrows for values between 67 and
33 percent and red arrow for values less
than 33 percent
now let us customize this rule for our
criteria
in the type drop down select the option
as number
in the value reference box enter value
is 8 000 for green color arrow and 5000
for yellow color Arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color Arrow click ok
in the conditional formatting rules
manager window click ok
we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8 000
have a green arrow in the upward
Direction
values between 5K and 8K are highlighted
with a yellow arrow and values less than
5K are highlighted with a red arrow
we can also apply conditional formatting
rule with the help of formulas consider
the given table which shows the profit
done by each salesman here we want to
highlight the rows in the table wherever
profit is greater than four thousand
select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting select
the option new rule from the drop down a
new formatting rule dialog box appears
under select rule type select the option
use a formula to determine which cells
to format
under format values reference box enter
the formula as equals if Open Bracket
dollar sign H2 greater than four
thousand comma true comma false close
bracket
this will apply formatting to a cell if
the profit is greater than four thousand
click on format button
from the format cells dialog box select
the fill tab from the color dialog box
select the color as green finally click
ok
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than four thousand are
highlighted with the green color
logical functions evaluate a cell or
cells for a criteria and returns a
Boolean value true or false
in this topic we will cover various
logical functions like if and or not
true false
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to determine the commission
percentage of each salesman
following is the criteria if net sales
greater than or equal to ten thousand
set commission as five percent
if net sales greater than or equal to
5000 and less than or equal to ten
thousand set commission as 2.5 percent
if net sales less than five thousand set
commission as one point five percent
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function
let's write the formula in cell I5
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function e if and then type an open
parenthesis the first parameter we need
to pass is a logical test here The
Logical test is if sales cell G5 greater
than or equal to ten thousand assign
value as five percent
then we will pass the second logical
test here we will use and function if
Open Bracket and Open Bracket sale at
cell G5 greater than or equal to five
thousand comma cell G5 less than or
equal to ten thousand comma assigned
value as 2.5 percent
in the else parameter we will type 1.5
percent this means that if the first two
cases become false then the formula will
assign the value 1.5
finally close the two braces for the two
IFS thus Excel Returns the result as 2.5
percent for cell G5
now drag the formula with the help of
the fill handle we can see the results
for the other cells as well
the or function returns true if any of
the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
in the given table we are required to
assign performance remarks for each
salesman as per the scaling table
in scaling table we have the criteria
that if net sales greater than 10 000 or
profit greater than 5000 set remark as
good
else set remark as needs Improvement
let's write the formula using IF and or
to check sales and maximum sales in cell
J5
so our formula becomes equals if Open
Bracket or Open Bracket G5 greater than
ten thousand comma H5 greater than or
equal to five thousand comma double
quote good double quote comma double
quote need Improvement double quote
close bracket
let's drag this formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
this formula returned true if any of the
condition is true thus in the given
example the cell j9 returns good even if
profit is less than five thousand
our next function is true false true
slash false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell
the not function reverses the result of
the function
if result is true it returns false else
true
let's write formula as equal not open
bracket K5 close bracket in cell L5
this Returns the result as false
let us now study about different lookup
and reference functions used in Excel
such as vlookup hlookup match index and
offset function
the vlookup function lets us search for
specific information in the current
worksheet
say we have a list of students with
marks we can search for the marks of a
specific student if our table is in
horizontal format and we want to
determine a specific value then we use
the hlookup function
consider the extract from our Master
sales table
the table depicts sales information
based on order ID Products sold salesman
and net sales now we want to determine
the net sales corresponding to order ID
let's understand how we can accomplish
this using the vlookup function
note that vlookup function is only used
for vertical tables let's use cell I2 to
add the formula
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function name
vlookup and then type and open
parentheses
now we will add the arguments the first
argument is lookup value lookup value
corresponds to the value or item we are
searching for
so in our example it will be order ID
1121 cell H2
the second argument is table array table
array is the cell range that contains
the data in this example our data is in
cell B2 to e40.
the third argument is called index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be
four
the fourth argument is range lookup this
value corresponds if we are looking for
approximate matches or not and can have
value either true or false true denotes
the approximate match and false denotes
the exact match here we will pass false
finally close the parentheses
so our function has the form equal
vlookup Open Bracket H2 comma B2 colon
E40 comma four comma false close bracket
we can see that the function Returns the
value as 2 2 7 7.
note that the vlookup function works
from left to right that means the lookup
value should always be present in the
leftmost column of our table array
if our table is in horizontal format and
we want to determine a specific value
then we use the hlookup function
consider the given table let's write the
formula in cell I4 we will start with
the equal sign then type our function
name
hlookup and then type open parentheses
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be order ID
equals one one two one
cell eight four
the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G8 to
as11.
the third argument is row index number
here our table array net sales is the
fourth row so our third argument will be
four the fourth argument is range lookup
here we will pass false finally close
the parentheses
so our function has the form equals
hlookup Open Bracket H4 comma G8 colon
as11 comma 4 comma fault close bracket
the function Returns the value to 277
note that each lookup function works
from left to right that means lookup
value should always be in the topmost
row of your table array
the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then Returns the
relative position of that item in the
array
let us understand its functioning with
the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell E5
type equal sign
then type the function name
match and then type an open parentheses
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be date in
cell B5
the second argument is lookup array
the lookup array is a range of cells
that contains the value we are searching
for in this example we will select the
cells B17 to b1342
the third argument is match type match
type can be either -1 0 or 1.
the value should be 1. if we want to
find the largest value less than or
equal to the lookup value
the value should be zero if we want to
find the first value exactly equal to
lookup value
it should be -1 if we want to find the
smallest value greater than or equal to
lookup value
here we will pass the match type as 0 as
we require an exact match
finally close the parentheses
so our function should look like match
Open Bracket B5 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
B dollar sign one three four two comma
zero close bracket
this Returns the value as three now we
can drag the formula across cells with
the help of the fill handle
similarly we can use the match formula
in cell E3 to determine the position of
the shown field name Excel C3 in range
B17 to I17 for example net sales is at
seventh position in the range B17 to I17
let's write the function in cell E3
write formula as equal sign match and
open parentheses in the first argument
select cell C3
for second argument select cells B17 to
I17
past third argument is zero finally
close the parentheses
so our function looks like equal match
Open Bracket C3 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
I dollar sign Seventeen comma zero close
bracket so for profit loss field the
value returned is 8.
net sale the value returned is seven
the index function Returns value from a
specified position in a specific column
in a list
suppose we want to determine the value
of a field mentioned in cell C3 from the
sales table on a specified date
the table should dynamically fetch the
value if the value of the cell C3 is
changed
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
if we write net sales in cell C3 then
formula should fetch net sales value for
specified date
so let's use the index function to
determine the value in this worksheet
select cell C5 write formula is equal
sign index and open parentheses
the first argument is the array for our
example enter B17 colon i1342
the second argument is the row num this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter E5 which denotes the required date
the third column is column
this corresponds to the column number
that has the value we want to return
here we will enter E3 which denotes the
position of the field name in cell C3 in
table
finally close the parentheses
thus our formula Returns the value as
6528 based on the position at cells E5
this is the net sales value on the date
the 2nd of January
now drag the formula with the fill
handle to the other cells as well
the offset function returns a reference
to a range that is the offset number of
the rows and columns from another range
or cell now let's understand how to use
it select cell D5
right formula is equal sign offset and
open parentheses the first argument is
the reference this denotes the starting
range from which the offset will be
applied for our example we will select
the reference cell as B17
the second argument is the rows this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or A negative number
so for our example we will enter E5
minus 1. here we are subtracting 1 to
match number of row which have the value
and the offset from the reference cell
the third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name and subtract by 1 to
match with the offset referencing
finally close the parentheses
the function Returns the value based on
the position of date from cell B5 and
field from cell C3
now drag the formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
a variety of statistical functions are
available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test binomial or
chi-square
in this topic we will cover various
statistical functions like sumif
countifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and median
some ifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
sum based on one or more criteria the
sumifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain criteria
let's understand how to use the function
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table say we want to
determine the net sales done by salesman
Justin
here we will use the sumifs function to
calculate net sales so let's write the
formula in cell N4 type equal sign then
type the function name sumifs and then
type an open parentheses the first
argument is the sum range this is the
input range that contains the required
data so in our example we will select
cells H4 to H 1328
the second argument is the criteria
range this denotes the range that
contains the required criteria here we
will pass the range that holds
salesman's name cells E4 to E 1328.
the third argument is criteria this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require net sales of the salesman
Justin so we will select cell M4
finally close the parentheses note that
we can pass multiple criteria in this
function the function Returns the net
sales done by Justin
countifs function Works in a similar
manner like sumifs it counts the number
of cells in a given range when certain
criteria is met
say in the given sales table we want to
determine the total number of sales for
net sales greater than 8 000. to
determine the count we will use the
countifs function so let's write the
formula in cell N5 type the equal sign
then type the function name
countifs and then type in open
parentheses the first argument is the
criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales H4 to h1328
the second argument is criteria one this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require entries with net sales
greater than eight thousand so we will
enter greater than 8 000. finally close
the parentheses
note that the function allows you to
enter multiple criteria
cell N5 reflects the total number of
sales as 445 for net sales greater than
eight thousand
in this topic we will learn how to use
the function's percentile quartile
standard deviation and median in Excel
consider the given sales table let's see
how to use the percentile function on
net sales to find its 40th percentile
select the cell n6 write the formula as
equal sign percentile Open Bracket
select the column net sales H4 to
h1328 as our first argument
pass the second argument as 0.4 in order
to find the 40th percentile
this Returns the result
5220 this means that 40 percent of the
net sales is less than or equal to 5220.
the next function is quartile quartile
function depicts the results for the
first second third and fourth quartile
say we want to find the total number of
sales which are less than or equal to 25
percent let's use the quartile function
to calculate this
select cell N7 to write the formula
type equal sign function name is
quartile and open braces
select net sales column H4 to
h1328 as the first argument
type 1 as the second argument
the second argument must be a number
between 0 and 4. the function returns a
value as
3822 which means that 25 percent of the
sale is less than or equal to 3822.
note that here we can use the percentile
function to perform the same task the
function percentile H4 to
h1328 comma 0.25 gives us the same
result it's up to us which function we
would like to use for the quartiles
Excel has a function to calculate sample
standard deviations stdev
[Music]
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean
say we want to calculate the standard
deviation for number of customers
so write the formula in cell N8 as
equals
the function name stdev
open braces
select number of customers columns as
its argument
the function returns a result 1.4
the median function Returns the value
from the range for example we want to
find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in cell N9 write the
formula as equal sign the function name
median then open braces
select net sales column as its argument
this calculates the mid value of net
sales as 6192
rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in a
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function Returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales
select cell j4 and write the formula as
equal sign then type the function name
rank and then type in open parenthesis
the first argument is the number
this is the value whose rank we are
required to calculate here we will pass
the argument cell H4
second argument is ref
this corresponds to the array or
reference list here we will select the
column net sales IE cells H4 to H 1328.
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and 1 denotes ascending
order
this argument is optional if we don't
pass any argument Excel automatically
takes the argument zero here we will
pass zero finally close the parentheses
here we can see that Excel has
determined the rank for net sales
7164 as 553
finally we can drag the formula and can
see the rank for the other cells based
on net sales
and that brings us to the end of our
video on business analytics and
intelligence full course by simply loan
I hope it was useful and informative if
you have any queries please feel free to
put them in the comment section of the
video we'll be happy to help you thanks
again stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here